en cette fin d'été on ne saurait
échapper au colonel chabert le film
d'abord bien sûr mais aussi le roman qui
est proposé en édition de poche dans pas
moins de huit collections différentes
vendues de 8 à 31 francs 50 la voc du
livre petit prix se répand à grande
vitesse relisons cet admirable histoires
de revenants comme l'a qualifié paul
morand chabert est une oeuvre de
jeunesse balzac la publie en 1832 il a
trente trois ans c'est un auteur lancé
par la peau de chagrin il et mondain
endettés séduisant et cette année là ils
rencontrent cette compagne d'une vie que
sera madame en ce cas plutôt bref dans
l'intrigué
sinon dans le style chabert est un conte
noir une tragédie intime tout baigné par
le souvenir de l'empereur
chabbert laissé pour mort à l eau il
mena la charge en héros revient je suis
celui qui est mort
le monde a changé sa femme s'est remarié
napoléon n'est plus sur les murs de
l'étude de maître der wiel l'ombre du
soldat est réapparu un spectre ou un
vivant un amnésique ou un fou on ne
revient pas impunément du royaume des
morts
il vous appelle vous requiert vous
aspirent
à